this is uh Beyond parody Donald Trump is
having such trouble doing like normal
interviews lately that he is
increasingly relegated to doing whack
job interviews the latest is with
conspiracy theorist Dinesh D'Souza and
it is quite frankly Beyond parody Dinesh
D'Souza is increasingly a darling of the
conspiracy right that believes Donald
Trump was actually the winner of the
2020 election Dinesh D'Souza made the
film 2000 mules this is a completely
farcical
obviously completely debunked film that
makes almost unfalsifiable claims based
on mobile phone geolocation data to
argue that because there were people
with mobile phones more or less near
ballot drop boxes at different times of
day during the early voting period in
2020 it is clear that they were caring
like mules remember that's the idea they
were mules for thousands or tens of
thousands of fraudulent ballots that
they were doing massive dumps with into
the drop boxes there's no evidence for
any of it widely debunked watch the film
if you want to blow two hours and then
uh research each of the claims and you
will find that it is vacant and vapid
but Trump loves it so Trump agreed to be
interviewed by Dinesh D'Souza and Donald
Trump's lies are getting more and more
sick and more and more disconnected from
reality if you can imagine that in this
first clip Donald Trump claims
some people voted 28 times on the Same
Day in 2020 this is a claim for which
there is no evidence there isn't a
little evidence
there isn't some evidence there is no
evidence for this claim and Dinesh
D'Souza just nods along and then of
course they voted six seven eight times
here as much as they could in the local
area some of the people went back I
guess they said 28 times and one no one
day to vote at different places with you
know numerous votes but they can't they
can't put in a thousand because it
wouldn't be a pro you know wouldn't look
right right
you they voted 28 times
because voting a thousand times would
raise suspicions but voting 28 times was
fine under whose names
they never answer that question just the
most fun oh if I David Pacman try to
vote 28 times in 28 different places at
each place I have to give some name and
it has to be someone who hasn't already
voted but it's registered in that
particular Precinct how would I get the
names what names did I give
they don't tell us no the people voted
28 times they're very smart you know
they're going with five vote six vote
seven votes and then they go to another
one but it adds up to millions of votes
yeah absolutely delusional and again
it's the blind leading the blind Dinesh
D'Souza just nodding nodding nodding
nodding along in the next clip Donald
Trump raises the conspiracy theory that
William Barr his own attorney general
this is not you know Merrick Garland the
Trump's own Attorney General William
Barr covered up the election fraud
because of fear he had of Democrats it
was wonderful they didn't even do
checking Bill Barr was afraid to be
impeached he was petrified of being
impeached and look at Dinesh D'Souza not
along to something so completely absurd
when William Barr had almost no time
left
in this office at the time that he
refused to participate in the lies and
the delusions why would that be William
Barr's fear
in November December and January of 2020
and 2021 respectively the Democrats said
they were going to
go and all of a sudden we have a an
attorney general who is afraid to talk
about he's saying oh the election was
just wonderful and it wasn't
you know William Barr was in the uh
George H.W bush Administration much
earlier in his career he didn't seem
afraid of anybody or anything there and
then he had a lot of work that he did in
the private sector and you would think
if he had a time to be afraid of
Democrats when it might have damaged his
future Private Industry career it would
have been when he was working for George
H.W bush and he wasn't afraid then why
would he be afraid at the end of 2020
the start of 2021 near the end of his
career it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever and then lastly Donald Trump
saying Fox News is not what it used to
be but listen carefully to the language
he uses talking about
it's much different than it was uh when
I first ran Fox I will tell you it's a
lot different talking about fox has
changed Fox is not doing for Trump when
he first ran and I know it says it
sounds like Trump is saying when I first
ran Fox what he means is when I first
ran Fox was different what Trump means
is what was ultimately a 100 percent
sycophant brown-nosing channel Fox News
is now only about 90 percent there
leaving themselves the escape hatch the
eject button in case Ron DeSantis or
someone else ultimately becomes the
nominee but that means you are on
Trump's naughty list you're no longer on
the nice list what a pathetic interview
and Trump reduced to being interviewed
by Dinesh D'Souza what a just totally
humiliating display and as usual as
usual
Trump only wants friendly interviews and
if it's anything but friendly sometimes
he'll hang up remember with NPR he'll
attack the interviewer the right way is
to ask Trump the questions tee up
softballs for him to knock out of the
park with lies and then just nod Dinesh
D'Souza really you know the right likes
to use the term NPC
Dinesh de Souza really playing the NPC
folks remember that our YouTube channel
is heading towards 2 million subscribers
this is an insane number for a little
old show like ours and the most
important piece of data I have for you
we have nearly three million existing
viewers who aren't subscribed and as
I've been talking about this more and
more of them email me and they say David
you know I watch you every day I checked
I'm not a subscriber I didn't need to
subscribe YouTube was already feeding me
all your videos very very important if
you were one of these we call them the
2.8ers there's about 2.8 million people
last month who watched our videos but
are not subscribed on YouTube you can
help us get to the 2 million subscriber
number like tomorrow if just you find
folks who watch but don't subscribe were
to hit that subscribe button we could be
there overnight youtube.com the
davidpackman show subscribe free it is
free and I will address this in the
voicemail L segment today we'll take a
quick quick break and be right back
when you're busy during the day and you
need a quick snack sometimes you're just
in the mood for something sweet that's
when I reach for monk pack our sponsor
monk pack offers gooey granola bars that
melt in your mouth as well as nut and
Seed bars that are perfectly crunchy
sweet and salty but the best part is
that each bar is plant-based with only
one gram of sugar two to three net carbs
and only about 150 calories it's great
if you're doing keto or low carb or like
me you just want to minimize your sugar
intake I can't get enough of dark
chocolate cocoa I'm just a chocolate guy
it's great but they come in other
flavors too like sea salt dark chocolate
caramel sea salt they just launched
peanut butter cocoa chip and dark
chocolate cocoa if you don't love monk
pack as much as our entire team does
monk pack will give you your money back
go try monk pack keto granola bars and
nut and Seed bars go to monkpak.com and
use the code Pacman for twenty percent
off the link is down below